part three of my parents bought a water  slide and the town did not want them to  put it up for those of you that haven't  seen it this is the slide  basically though at the town hall thing  my dad found a loophole and the loophole  basically was that you not you're not  allowed to have a structure taller than  the house but you can they can't tell  you how  tall to make a structure that you attach  to your house so if you make addition to  your house they can't tell you how tall  to make that this is the part where you  go down the slide i'll show you what my  dad did  so he  just attached to the structure to our  porch  therefore they could not stop us  building the slide because the structure  was part of our house so yeah then we  built the slide and now it's up and  running funny thing is though it's a  small town so when they figure out i'm  from the house with the water slide you  get two reactions it's either  oh  or  oh that's awesome and that's the